nice
[Music]
uh well today I'm not exactly joined by
a lad but whatever the female equivalent
for one is then in this episode I have
one of the greats she has a CV that
would make any athlete proud having won
a gold medal at the Commonwealth Games
and the Olympics and the Seven aside
format while also winning a seventh
Rugby World Cup and the 15 aside game
she's won not only one but two Rugby
World Cups and along the way she's been
a massive part in growing the women's
game not just here in New Zealand but
around the world she is of course the
ever smiling Legend herself Stacy Walker
welcome wow
I mean
so I'm very excited to be
on thanks for coming on I know this has
been in the pipeline for a while pretty
much since that Rugby World Cup but it's
nice to finally both have some mutual
time off where we can get this done yeah
absolutely
brother
um I wasn't giving you the scene for on
purpose
but yes a little bit of downtime so I'm
still stoked to be on yeah but what a
what are 12 months it's been for you
like looking back at your last sort of
12 months on the field with the sevens
and the 15s game
um you must look back at that and just
sort of pinch yourself a little bit yeah
it was interesting because actually if I
rewind 12
bronze and the Commonwealth Games and
then silver at the sevens World Cup
obviously not what we wanted
um so it was a goal of ours to get to
that 15s World Cup and try and win it at
home um and and we did so went from
third to second to first place then it's
still such a surreal feeling um I've
Loved bouncing between sevens and 15s
since I debuted like eight years ago
yeah
um but to win to win Pinnacle events
obviously to play in them as a pretty
special feeling
um but to win it definitely puts the
cherry on top of the cake you mentioned
bumping in between the two sports how
hard is that how do you find that going
from sevens to 15 and back and forth
um if I'm honest I actually really enjoy
it um I definitely find it harder
transitioning from 15s to sevens than I
do the other way around obviously a
little bit fitter a little bit faster
leaner
um sometimes you have to bulk up more
for 15s
um and not as much running I suppose in
terms of speed outputs but I do enjoy it
it keeps my mind fresh
physically such a different demand I
suppose in both codes but I I definitely
do enjoy the subtle changes between both
yeah and I guess the group dynamics are
completely different as well isn't it
you've got different teammates different
cultures how do they compare oh I
actually love like sevens you're with
this group of girls
um small amount of girls obviously only
contracted 12 on every tour and then you
go to 15's and a squad of 32
um 23 playing on Saturdays I actually
quite like The Vibes like I know I'm
full-time servants every day I see them
but you go into the 15s environment and
there's people from all over New Zealand
um you know you get to connect with
girls that you don't usually see often
unless you're playing against or with
them on a rugby field and I think that's
probably made my career more special is
that I get to have those connections
with so many different people from all
around the country yeah and those
connections are what it's all about eh
like that's the coolest part of the game
really isn't it yeah absolutely I mean
if you look back on your career once you
do finish it's those little memories
that you make along the way traveling
the world
um that little banter that everyone has
within the team you know how it is but
it keeps it fun and that's why I love
playing rugby yes because because of the
connections because we love the game and
we get to travel everywhere and it must
be pretty special at the moment
especially in the sevens game you guys
are you guys are on absolute fire you're
on off you're on fire but you guys seem
to be winning every tournament and like
you say you're traveling the world with
an awesome bunch of girls winning
tournaments it must be it must be you
must sort of be on cloud nine
actually like talking about it yet we're
five out of six World Series wins I
think we um potentially just have to
make the quarter this next tournament so
no pressure but um is that to win the
competition who won the World Series
yeah and and oh true we feel a little
bit ripped off last year because we
missed four tournaments out of the seven
we only got to play three we still
managed to get fifth overall considering
we missed a lot of them
um so yeah with I suppose a goal for us
first was to qualify for the Olympics
and when we managed to achieve that in
Vancouver a couple months ago
um and then it'd be pretty awesome to
win the World Series this year before
heading into a massive Olympic year next
year um but I know we we're not perfect
uh we haven't been the best team perfect
I don't think any team's ever perfect
um but we have been winning and you know
whether it's an inch or a mile we've got
to take those
um
wins yeah game by game tournament where
tournament in I suppose now the biggest
thing is refining refining the small
errors that we're making and being
consistent I like that so you only have
to make the quarter final have you ever
not made the quarterfinal like you guys
seem to always be at least in the finals
right yeah not from what I remember but
it's still tough it's still tough you
know these sevens is a very fast Sports
and if you look at the men's format man
there's some teams who who just come out
of the blue from nowhere and there's
definitely female teams there who can
who can surprise you sometimes
um but we'll take it game by game and
hopefully we can't get there
surely surely surely quarter finals
please
anyway as always I do like to start the
podcast by sort of going through the
Journey from the start to hear how these
Legends become the legends that they are
and talk me through
um you're sort of upbringing I know your
brother quite well I got to play with
him for a year in the necky but other
than that I don't know too much about
the upbringing so I'm looking forward to
hearing about it yeah I feel sorry for
you that you had to play
I'll credit him I'll credit my brother's
voting in France
um I honestly reckon if it wasn't tab
for having big brothers on the baby of
the family there's four of us my older
sister two older brothers and then
there's me
um grew up around a lot of whanau
friends
um and I honestly I'm grateful because
they made things a lot tougher than um
they should have been but I think it
made it hardened me out for the sport
um but yeah upbringing off
um a little bit of a different story
from me so I was actually the only child
out of my siblings born in New Zealand
mum and dad were back and forth between
Melbourne and Auckland for quite a few
years because I work dad played rugby
um and yeah he went okay unfortunately
he chose my mum over Sports so he didn't
quite make it um lucky his kids did for
him
uh yeah so um move back and forth and
then went back to Melbourne when I was
one and my first eight years years of
life actually was in Melbourne Australia
that's true uh yeah heaps of whanau
there
um played netball we all played sport
obviously followed dad and my brother's
down to the um Rugby Club every weekend
and you know I feel like everyone kind
of does that here in New Zealand anyway
it's the part of our life and culture
yeah
um and then one year me and Beau
actually we we loved coming home back to
ruatuki to the farm to our Nan every
Christmas holiday so mum and dad would
send us back obviously riding the horses
by motorbikes
um down at the river with all our
friends and our cousins and everyone who
kind of lived in in the house
um and we just loved it so much that we
didn't want to move back uh so we pretty
much cried to mum and dad on the phone
what were we eight and nine years old
um and said we don't want to get on the
plane and that's when Mom and Dad
realized it was time to come home back
to New Zealand and they packed up
everything since at home on a shipping
container and yeah we started now I
suppose our young kid life here in
duratuki loved it loved the rural
lifestyle so peaceful and quiet so many
people around all the time
um and yeah I think the coolest thing
was we're very competitive whanau so we
hate losing yeah
um we're very harsh from each other very
stubborn people we're all the same but
um I think I love that because we grew
that competitive nature with one another
and that led um to the sports field was
actually quite tough
um being brought up in this um small
Maori town uh on honest honestly we were
all like very fair everyone thought we
were from Australia no one really new
Austin if it wasn't for sport if it
wasn't for us joining our sports teams
at school I don't think we I think we
would have struggled um because they
quickly they kind of quickly realized
we're okay at playing phone and they
wanted to be on our team so we're like
oh okay this is our way in to try and
fit in with everyone that looked sort of
us is different I suppose
um and then yeah obviously my friends
and everyone realized oh actually they
are from here
um and so yeah it kind of just flowed on
from there played sport obviously both
sent away to boarding school which was
probably cool for him because rugby
contracts led him to taranaki with you
guys
um and I actually originally just loved
nipple and touch I wanted to be a silver
Fern that was my Ultimate Dream nothing
else was on the radar until year 11 I
think I played my first game of rugby
for whakatane high school and just never
looked back sure so yeah played played
kind of everything at school you know as
kids do you just like to have a bit of
fun and whatnot
um but that's how I suppose my
transition started oh net netball would
be gutted are they
I know I definitely don't think I'd fit
in there now
um way too hard for me but yeah I
definitely love running on the field not
the court yeah what were you like at
touch you must have been pretty good at
touch as well I'd imagine yeah no love
touch
um so I played with everyone all my
family that was quite cool like every
weekend I was at touch tournaments and I
I'm so grateful that I play touch I
honestly reckon if I didn't it wouldn't
have made me be the better rugby player
that I am today
um but I think 40 I was 14 when I made
the New Zealand under 15s team and had
so far I remember it clearly it had to
fundraise three thousand dollars to get
to um to Australia and we're so poor
like honestly mum and dad struggled for
years trying to get jobs and just to
feed us and it was very different it was
a contrast upbringing actually because
women in Australia were I wouldn't say
we were rich but we had money yeah um
and you know could go and do all these
things had things and then we came back
to New Zealand and it kind of went
crashing down when mum and them couldn't
really find these jobs so it was a real
tough time but I'm so grateful for my
family and and just the community like
buying raffle tickets and you know
sponsoring me all these things just to
represent our country and it was a cool
experience
um and then when I learned rugby
actually paid you I was like
here we go let's choose the sport now
um and yeah very grateful to this day so
you made that three thousand dollars
from raffle tickets was that yeah yeah
pretty much oh but yeah mum and dad did
he they had like a cards night they did
a hangy fundraiser batons up like
literally did everything and that's cool
that was obviously to buy gear too
because I had the you know the old Wadi
fuddy boots back in the day but hey it's
I was grateful because it got me around
the field it's all good and I guess you
couldn't complain either really because
you were the ones who wanted to be back
in New Zealand so you had to put up with
that exactly exactly the reason why they
moved home and honest cigar to this day
my my older sister and brother they hate
us they're like we had our lives sorted
over there because they were like four
or five years older they had their plans
like in the high school kind of thing
um and they blame us for not getting the
opportunities that we got growing up oh
wow tough luck
work for 12 view anyway yeah
wow Craig
and I guess um in the backyard and stuff
when you're playing rugby you would have
been some of those games would have been
pretty competitive that's sort of the
first memory I remember from you as all
the boys giving sort of Bodine
about her sister being better than him
at rugby and um they saw that in their
backyard but they can't have been too
far wrong I guess
no well yeah I actually felt focused on
my new head always get a bit of stick
from from the boys he Stills it to me
this way he's like oh if it wasn't for
me you would have never made it I'm like
okay well if you think so
um but like I said obviously real
grateful
um to have two older brothers who
hardened me up and yeah I I think it
definitely helped my skill set yeah so
when you did give rugby your first crack
was that physicality side of it not
intimidating for you at all I guess
that's probably the biggest turn off for
a lot of young girls is that sort of big
collisions and tackling and that sort of
stuff it was probably you're probably
used to it yeah I was I mean my mindset
and my aggression was there but I'm not
sure about my techniques so
I had to learn I had to learn throughout
the year how to properly tackle um but I
definitely was Fearless
um because of having my two brothers
there and I think too I was real
grateful because I know I had a few
friends whose parents weren't very
excited about them playing or who didn't
let them playing because it was such a
physical sport and I knew mum and dad
always just wanted us to do what made us
happy so have to credit them too for
letting me play a sport that wasn't very
female dominant I suppose back then um
but so many opportunities now and I'm
hoping that and households are we've got
more support backing on young females to
play the game yeah well the games
changed massively even in the last sort
of 12 months post that World Cup
especially like how much that women's
game has changed it's been pretty
incredible oh it's been massive and I
know when they announced the World Cup
at home to be really honest we were all
talking like oh are we gonna film seats
like are people going to actually come
watch the game yeah I mean after the
opening round I was like well actually
people people are watching and then
obviously semis and finals came and it
was a sellout and yeah I don't know I
suppose it just happened in such a short
space of time and to actually win a
World Cup at home it's such a surreal
feeling and people keep asking me
they're like oh what's better you've won
a Rugby World Cup you won an Olympic
gold medal and it's real tough because
obviously the Olympics are like the
Pinnacle right of sport around the world
everyone knows about it everyone wants
to go there and I'm grateful like Frick
we've won a gold medal but it just
wasn't the same feeling like yeah no
crowd no family support but the 15s
everyone was there you could rent to the
um what do you call it the crowding I
don't know just big hugs and everything
so yeah that's pretty cool and I guess
those games were so 10 it's in
um tight that um they were sort of down
last night I feel like it made it more
exciting to watch and obviously being
out there and tough
what would I say I don't know close
gains coming down to a kick or coming
down to a line out it's like moments
that you get in those pressure moments
that get the crowd off their feet and
I'm just glad we're on the right side of
it of the result yes so was the whole
country I think that was that was
unbelievable how the whole uh the whole
nation sort of got him behind you like
you said at the start everyone at the
start of the tournament was potentially
doubting how much of a following they
were going to get but by the end of it
everyone I remember being at the pub
watching the final one the crowd at that
Pub was just so in behind you girls it
was unbelievable scenes I think that's
probably
the coolest part about it was like so
many people who have never seen women's
rugby in their life whether they were
young kids older people like so many
different Generations in to see them now
backing us I'm like yeah we did that we
did that but there's still a job to do
for me I'm like oh we need more home
games so we we continue that momentum I
suppose we want more people jumping on
board and I know we've got a whole new
coaching career that have just been
announced um and there are tests coming
up but yeah I just hope for the future
of this game
um that yeah people continue backing it
and and it's not just like a one-off
because it was a World Cup at home yeah
yeah 100 what do you make of the new uh
coaching team I saw that what that was
announced today wasn't it yeah yeah
yeah a little bit surprised only because
I'm oh I don't know why I'm surprised I
don't really know who was going for it
to be honest
um it's cool it's exciting it's a new
new group I have personally don't know
them like you know on um
on that kind of level obviously know
that they've come from amazing
backgrounds and
um and whatnot but I know Bunce um will
be there helping supporting them and and
make sure that this next campaign
hopefully we can go back to back to back
to go
how good would that be that'd be so good
but I do want to get back to the sort of
start of when you made the black ferns
you said that you gave rugby a go you
were you pretty much loved it straight
away so then what was your pathway
because I know it happened all pretty
quick for you
yeah that
um so yeah yeah pretty much played a
whole season and now
singing competition like with unheard of
on there there's a little schools
we used to struggle to get numbers two
games to be honest
um and then got picked up from the Bay
of Pliny sevens
um coach kind of scouted me
played that we weren't the greatest back
then um but it was good fun what
position what position were you playing
back then
um yeah so for 15. I was actually a full
bet which was really weird because they
wanted me with ball in hand but they
also didn't kick a lot so I'm not sure
how that worked but it was all good I
seem to get the horse though um which
was fun running around I could not
kicked on the same myself both my
brothers both first five half backs or
both have great kicks on them and I
didn't get that Gene so that's why I'm
stuck in the Midfield just run
um and yeah Stevens I kind of just
played anywhere back then had no idea
about positions
um just gave everything a go so then
your next step from there you make that
team and then how do you become a black
Fern from there yeah and then I actually
went to one of the go for gold programs
the bear plini one
um and pretty much got told you're not
fit enough and you sort your nutrition
out and fair enough because I wasn't I
was literally there just
um just having fun with my friends and I
remember no one absolutely no one from
the bay actually made the next step for
that program true yeah so what none of
us are good enough obviously and then
um the New Zealand team sevens team got
named and and whatnot
um so we had to make the move I I feel
like the pathway back then 2013 was yeah
my last year high school
um it wasn't the greatest for women's
rugby and the best decision for me
obviously education was always going to
be first which was why I went to um
waikato uni for that and then I knew
waikato rugby were quite strong female
rugby
um it was the closest place to home
and so yeah made the decision to go
there and that's pretty much where I
credit the start of my woman rugby
career because it was my first year
playing FBC first year playing Club
rugby
um and that's probably where I got
picked up from from the New Zealand
coaching setup because the following
year I made my debut for the 15. yeah
like one full year in your own
oh
I remember going so it also work up in
2014 and it's my first year out of high
school and um a few of us drove up to
the blackfinch trials that year and I
remember watching it like wow this is so
cool with matching being here one day on
honest to God I never ever thought it
would be a year later yeah I I don't
know it just wasn't in my thoughts I was
like oh one day
um and then it happened and I was like
oh this is great
and how did that affect your study what
and what were you studying oh yeah
I agree that you need
love being
um and so I was lucky because I managed
to do two full years of uni before I got
picked up
with um my sevens contract
um so when I made my debut in 2015 I
think the payback then was 50 a day and
honest honestly I was so stoked because
I was a uni student on student allowance
living in the halls and then we went
away for I might have been three and a
half weeks to Canada that's where I made
my day boo so I thought I was so rich
I'm like yes I've got all this money
from waiting for New Zealand and I I
clearly remember the first day we got
outfitted before this kits and shoes and
boots I was like whoa this is so so cool
so to come from 50 oh for fifty thousand
I wish fifty dollars a day back then to
the contracts we have now it's been a
massive growth in that area and yeah
it's kind of cool to to experience both
ends of the spectrum
obviously we all play rugby because we
love it but when there's little
incentives in behind it it definitely
makes it more special yeah so how did
you juggle it back then so obviously you
weren't making enough to live off it so
would you had to have a full-time job or
part-time job or how are you how are you
yeah
um I actually I was lucky I was on the
student Hillary scholarship which paid
all my fees free gem membership and he
got to do all these leadership courses
but through that program
um I was a friend of a friend who one
who needed a job in the um it was
actually the offices in the library that
used to run all the fees for the
University so it's kind of like an
accounting job sort of because you had
to organize all the money no experience
whatsoever like honestly never never did
anything at school or what but I got it
because I was on the suit
scholarship
um so yeah I had that part-time job for
a little while for that year I suppose
um to to afford to do things be a
student still try my hardest to make um
the New Zealand team and then I remember
the end of that year I got told my first
year uni um I had missed out on a
Stevens contract
um but you can still you'll still be
invited to camps and you know still
train hard still work hard we see
potential blah blah blah so
um it took another whole year before I
actually got my first seventh contract
um but I think that the special thing is
I debuted 15s before sevens
um people yeah forget that and that's
why I suppose I I hold a special place
in my heart for 15s because that was my
first black Jersey that was my debut
um and so yeah it's kind of cool that
I've been able to play both since then I
mean yeah pretty pretty special to be
able to do that but you mentioned
um the black Ferns and your debut
um what was it like when you're first in
that camp obviously there wasn't a lot
of money like you said what was the
culture and what's the environment like
was it professional or what was it like
going in there the first time oh yeah it
was it was amazing and to this day I
could you not like even if you ask every
single girl who went on that tour that
was 100 our favorite Tour Ever
um it was no Pinnacle event I think the
most special thing was they came off the
back of losing that World Cup against
Ireland so they didn't make
Sims or finals um and they're all gutted
I think there are 12 of us who debuted
there was just no pressure we had a
whole new Management Group lots of new
faces
um and there was it was just about going
out there to have fun like if we lost we
lost it's all good let's just make this
tour as fun as we could and the
management group that we had definitely
made it fun so I remember
um trying to do my first uh trials for
the gaming it was intense obviously
because she's trying to represent your
country but at the same time they always
just made it all about having fun
um so whether you're testing with a
hacker practice why to practice whatever
it was it was just I don't know it's
those memories that you you kind of
never forget especially when it's your
first time I feel like it's always going
to be a massive impression for you when
you're in an environment for the first
time and
um yeah so when we went over to Canada I
was just officially grateful to to be on
a plane
um again traveling representing our
country I was like whoa this is cool 19
years old
um I thought I thought I was the man
getting paid that much and getting
getting to represent obviously my family
um on the world page but it was it was
definitely a cool tour Canada was
awesome
um and I'll yeah I'll never forget the
moments with the girls
um who who sprays rode their wave with
yeah and you've been in that side
throughout the whole
um sort of last whatever years what is
it eight years or something how long has
it been yeah yep
yep it I I found it cool because I've
transitioned with so many different
players like I got to experience being
with you know the the older experience a
little bit more scarier
okay I won't say names
so they were in the girls game as well
yeah
yeah and um taking it as it comes and
then obviously growing into leadership
roles within the team
and and just seeing the difference with
a change you've kind of make
um with with everything really game
plans with culture with whatever the
game brings you so yeah it's been pretty
awesome Jenny is it is there a hierarchy
or like any Traditions you girls have
now which um have managed to you know
last the time they're actually on honor
there's probably not anymore
so much
um I know oh potentially in 15s actually
no that changed last year the other
usually backseat Bandits
um definitely not in sevens really
um there's zero tradition and sevens in
dreams because you're all in a van
aren't you usually yeah there's not many
of us
um but I remember 15s there used to be
the clean the boots if you were nude or
all that sort of stuff oh that's true
but from memory when I think to the
World Cup and they were oh even just end
of year tour the one where we got
slaughtered from France they were they
were in no Traditions there so maybe
we'll have to try and bring some back
just to make it more fun we're so nice
boots cleaned
we all too nice to each other
yeah but you did mention that to uh um
over in the UK which obviously didn't go
to plan and it was only what 12 months
before the World Cup how are you feeling
then how was the how are the girls feel
feeling then about the upcoming
tournament and were they still confident
that they could do it
but I still enjoyed it and I suppose
that's probably because I came from
sevens and obviously a fresh new
environment obviously coming in and out
all the time and heaps of new faces
um and yeah results didn't go away
probably not conditioned enough maybe
played wrong game plan at times
um but
um I definitely know
it was probably a blessing
um if we had a one nothing would have
changed maybe
um who knows and no one knows now but to
be able to turn it around within 12
months with new management new players
um that's pretty special and and it will
probably go down in history as one of
the greatest World Cups ever what was
the greatest turnarounds to be fair with
in such a short time frame yeah man it
was it was pretty impressive so you
spoke about the um coaching staff what
did they all add obviously Wayne Smith
Graham Henry what are these two sort of
add to the group yeah well I was
actually at the start of black ferns
with when Glenn Moore was head coach and
me and him had a really good
relationship like I learned so much of
him and he got chucked in the DP and I
remember
um
we had someone else as our coach and
then when we went away on to tour on
Canada he literally met us two days
before we flew out
um to be our head coach so he knew
nothing about any one of us he'd never
pushed woman rugby before
um so I think that's why it was special
during that tour because we won
um and he made these real cool
connections and and trying to learn so
much within a short time to try and be
England and Canada who had just played
in the final of the World Cup the year
before
um so yeah over the years been on the GM
for so many so I I like crediting him
for the value I suppose and the growth
that I got from his game so yeah a
little bit disappointing with the whole
situation that went on but coming back
into 15s from sevens under Smithy and
Ted
um oh it was it was wicked I actually
thought to be really honest
I've never been so I suppose scared
being in the black friends because of
the way he coached like he was very
direct very honest
um and he wasn't shy to call you out
whether you did good things or bad
things so yeah you just had to suck it
up he literally just had to suck it up
and if you stuffed up and got pointed
out it's like oh well move on like don't
do that again kind of thing
um and
when since transitioning from both it
was always similar game plans obviously
maybe a couple of new things here and
there or when a whole Management Group
changed our whole game plan changed so
we came in after com games and World Cup
for sevens and so this world cup
campaign pretty much having to learn a
whole new playbook
um because everything was different and
me Porsche and gossy we actually talked
about how much homework we had to do at
night talking to the girls obviously
they had all been together that year
playing pac-4 they played in the L'Oreal
O'Reilly series all together so they
knew the game plan in and out whereas we
were kind of like I felt like an
outsider again like obviously I was a
bit older I debroed seven years before a
lot of the girls on the team but you did
feel like a new person because of all
the new stuff um but I suppose when
you're passionate about something you do
you put in the hard Mahi
um you go and talk to who you need to
talk to make sure you know your position
as good as you can
um and yeah we managed to to pull it off
and and kind of fit in with the girls as
best as we could in terms of the game
plan yeah he certainly looked like you
fed him but that is an underrated
Skillet having to learn a whole play but
all the calls all those little micro
calls that Yeah you sort of become sick
in nature they need to become second
nature so you can just make that cool
yeah learning that in a whole new
playbook in that short time frame it's
not easy it was
tactic pass
you know all these different things and
then you've got to learn all these other
ones and then sometimes the name's
overlapped
um so we we would call something and
then it's like oh no that's wrong that's
that's a kick passing sevens well that's
a must pass the sevens here it's
whatever whatever else it was going to
Fifteen so it was confusing at times but
also the cool thing was there's a enough
of us I suppose sevens girls I hate to
included but we were the seventh girls
in the 15s team
um who had played together who had those
connections so we could kind of have our
own little connections on the field and
say things that other girls didn't know
and it would work
um yeah which probably made it more
special and made us feel more calm being
on the field
um playing this new game plan and the
new game plan was pretty much for when
smoothie rang us and we had our
conversations with him about being in
the team it was like he wanted to play
15s like sevens I was like oh oh yeah we
like that speed it up we like to play a
fast game
um so it probably fits at us quite well
actually uh trainings were so tough but
so good at the same time yeah what was
different about the trainings in terms
of the toughness was it like the context
or just him always barking orders yeah
it was just like real intense I knew
when it needed to be obviously there was
a good balance of um having our easy
days when we needed to but honestly the
Thursday trainings was our Double Days
um so we'd have one in the morning and
in the afternoon was pretty much just
full-on like you just smoke each other
this is two days before paying a test
match
um but that was our last kind of Smash
and Bash do the game plan and hit that
the level of detail that Smithy has on
his game plans did you see all the
papers and his um in his room
um of like his focuses for training was
Focus for for the game that week it was
it was detailed there but he had always
try and simplify it for us on game day
so usually have two focuses for us for
the week
um it could be like site the receiver
was one of them and the next one was
play through the line like little little
detailed things but he'd constantly say
it throughout the week that it'd just
stick and you'd know you're like oh yeah
I know what he wants us to do
um so yeah his game plan sheets honestly
were unreal detailed right down to every
single line out what player he wanted
off that line out
um and the one cool thing I actually
loved about him
um with as a Bex coach and and with
moves is we probably had
two or three Midfield moves and maybe
two backs moves but so many options off
them so yeah the year before we'd have
this Playbook of like 20 different moves
that you had to try and know and we were
all good because we'd been in the team
for so long you just learn it you just
know it because yeah the same names
every single year they never changed uh
maybe we added something in but yeah he
literally only had two moves for us and
or two or three moves in just you had to
choose the right option at the right
time depending on the defense um yeah so
yeah learned a lot learned a lot a lot
of um smelly the professor
um and he he didn't even know who we
were like he never watched us play
sevens or rugby before he just trusted
that the people around him were like
yeah I suppose they can they can play
too they they 15's players not just
sevens players yeah so that was cool too
that he didn't know our skill sets or
who we were or whatever we had to prove
ourselves every single week in and out
um which was cool and it's so
interesting fascinated hearing that
insight and especially hearing that
about the wizard like obviously he's got
the reputation when it's worth of being
The Mastermind coach and hearing some of
that it's pretty pretty cool but when
did you feel confident that you guys had
turned the corner and you're you're a
chance to win this competition obviously
the 12 months earlier like we spoke
about not great but when did you feel
like oh we've got the goods here we
could go the whole way oh
after the pool stages so I actually
picked up an injury so I didn't play the
second or third game I um strained my
Hemi in the first match the opener I was
so gutted
um but you know injuries happen it's all
good managed to come back four quarters
um but I feel like that belief really
hit after we got the results
um from those three games they were
quite big school lines first game was a
bit scary 17 nil down uh not the
greatest front open I've managed to pour
that one back
um yeah that's when we started thinking
okay who are we gonna cross over with um
played Wales twice played them in the
quarterfinal and then obviously came up
against Frampton
we knew fronts were going to be tough
like they're if they've grown so much
they've put so much into their game too
over there
um and
they they were gutted because they
didn't actually get to play us at the
last World Cup
um so when they beat us at India tour
they are stoked because they finally got
to play against us and then they beat us
like damn it
um but yeah that's probably where the
bully set and and they kept talking
about it actually I I remember our
meetings it was all like
cliche like we're great rugby players
we've got the right game plan to try and
win a World Cup but it all comes down to
mental toughness and the belief that you
kind of have in yourself we all knew if
we just played our own game
um you know stuck to what we knew and
just played what was in front that was
probably going to help us so yeah a few
different scary moments and those series
of finals games but it's all good now
it's all good because you know we did it
even the semi-final was it the
semi-final uh the French kicker had the
kick to win oh man oh I I would never
ever forget that moment I remember
looking up at the crowd and just being
like how can we lose like this we can't
lose a game to a kit I'd literally given
I didn't watch the kick it wasn't until
the crowd just stood up and roared I
remember turning my head and all I can
see was the ball Landing in Kennedy's
hands to the side of the post and she
just ran yeah I've never run so fast to
try and be a forward to secure Iraq like
just a little bit trying to be like no
we can't lose her and I actually have
nightmares I'm gonna bring it up and I
hate talking about this but 2020 FPC
final waikato vs Christchurch in
Christchurch I can't be in Christchurch
we literally had the game and there was
maybe five seconds we had to hold the
ball and we got turned over in a rock
and they played play played and scored
and beat us oh I will never forget the
moment I I was so gutted because the
game was out yeah it was we literally
just had to hold on to it five more
seconds kick it out um and that was that
was actually what I thought of in that
moment I was like oh my God just secure
the ball hold it and kick it out
so yeah it's amazing what student
experiences give you in certain parts of
games yeah well that waikato losses
obviously um come back to help New
Zealand with you racing to clean that
rack and secure that breakdown so that
we win the semi-final but then talk to
me about the final obviously sold out
Eden Park up against England
um what a game it was and one moment in
particular the trial of the century
people call it the girls version of the
Benji Marshall Grand Final flick pass
you're on fire talk me through that try
yeah well I'll be honest here I actually
hurt I'm myself at trading on the
Thursday and I was like why are we doing
this contact drill two days before I
write female account final I was oh
Garden so we'd always do contact
um before we'd do game scenarios on the
Thursday afternoon and it was wet the
field was terrible and I went in and I
got tackled from the side and I honestly
reckon I got like Charlie in the side of
my knee to the Bone though and I don't
know if you've ever been had a Charlie
in the bone
um but oh it was so sore I managed to
still continue training but I was so
worried I was like no I can't I can't
not play this final like so the next day
I literally laid on my bed getting ready
the whole day I was like nah nah I just
need to do nothing until the final got
to warm up and kind of sprinted and I
was like you know what jinlin's gonna
kick in I know it adrenaline's gonna
kick her that's a real Cup Final you're
good kind of stripped it a little bit I
did like this little tape around
underneath just probably more mental you
can't do anything
um and yeah I just yeah you would have
probably no one would have even on I
suppose that I had I played this final
hurt a little bit yeah it's definitely
you can show that when you guessed in
that sideline I know I know I know and
even in that moment like there was no
pain WhatsApp just the last thing you're
thinking of when you're running in space
but I I just remember being in the sheds
and
um the the talk
for talk being
um you know it's it's all good like very
calm out there continue doing what we're
doing
um but we need to start strong like
second half you know this is going to be
the most important start and this is
gonna you know kind of make or break us
um to try and win this world cup and
yeah when the ball came out
um I just ran I was like I don't know in
my head I was just like you know what
just run just run and I'm being really
honest when I did the little kind of
dummy it was a really dummy I kind of
just looked um I saw I saw skirt in the
corner of my eye so when I looked and it
was Aisha like she is the hardest
hardest player to tackle honestly she's
just like this rocket coming at you and
you cannot stop it
um when I seen her and I knew scared
would be worried about her kind of
running into her Channel I was like okay
this is the little conversation I'm
having in my head in this Split Second
as you do on the field
um yeah I just remember looking in the
corner of my eye and seeing her kind of
pull up a bit and I was like yes that's
exactly what I want you to do so
obviously carried on running and it was
Renee is actually so good at it and I
have to credit her she runs the best
support lines like always there always
through the line always cutting the
right people off and I heard her scream
my name I just heard it say Stacy right
I was like oh yep sweet just hit to draw
in the next person
luckily gave the pass and I actually
started stumbling a bit because I hit
the girl I think it was Zoe Harrison
their first wife I hit her in contact
after I had passed it and then I was
kind of just looking up and I saw heaps
of people Kinja I think everyone was
running all these mean support lines I
was like oh yep she'll probably pass
back in until I realized that she
actually veered out my way and I was
like oh I'm gonna get there I'm gonna
get there so yeah pretty much just ran
in the way she kinda
ran and cut I think it was Ali kill done
off to not let her get to me I was so
grateful so I I have to give that try to
hurt because
yeah I maybe initially started it oh
well actually it started from the
kickoff so you've got to credit the
forward so we've been hard money up
front
um it's yeah she definitely done a great
job to to definitely set me up in that
corner yeah and then what's the thrill
once you go over
what's that feeling like no well
smoothie hates me eh for going so close
to the sideline and I said um and I said
well you know you've gotta I've always
been told you gotta get as close as you
can to that post for your kicker and I
knew Renee was cooking it so I was like
okay she's just getting me up here I
need to get as far in as I can so she
can get the cook and I'm so good because
yeah I nearly ran out are you I knew I
knew where the Deadpool line was I
everyone how close were you I didn't
notice you being close
and smelly he replied her he kept
replaying it to me and he was like look
at your foot look at your foot I'm like
yeah yeah
and the worst thing is is Renee missed
the kick so I was like
[Laughter]
um but nah it was so good there's you
know those little moments you can think
about
um end of the day it's all good yeah you
got the chocolates and you won the cup
you won the World Cup how good and then
what are the celebrations like what
what's the black food celebration like
after a Rugby World Cup victory at home
in front of us sold out Eden Park
um the best feeling afterwards was going
to your family just giving them big hugs
and you know there to celebrate that
Victory it was like oh this is amazing
this is such a cool feeling and then it
led to obviously the presentations and
then we started getting kicked inside
um after you know I was just I just
wanted to stay out there all night and
thank everyone for being there and
supporting us and staying like two three
hours after the final was still had
blown yeah because they were you know
they were stoked that we won a World Cup
but we were stoked that people were just
there watching
um so yeah I tried my best to do just go
and see everyone obviously Family First
always
um but yeah eventually got kicked inside
um and I was injured so I'm like
hobbling around on my sprained ankle
that's right um went inside obviously
opened up a bottle first things first
gotta celebrate with a little beverage
and then we got kicked out of the shed
to go do media I had to do all that sort
of stuff
um and of course the Rugby World Cup
final Stacy gets injured and get cited
for drag this thing
even after the World Cup final wow it's
painful I was so good so me and Jonah
were the two one two picks I was like
interesting um scored a try and then the
one who won us the real cut with her
hands got picked okay it was this
randomly picked or
um so yeah we had to stay behind and do
our drug testing while everyone got to
celebrate on the bus you know singing
dancing laughing celebrating with just
run a Rugby World Cup and we're just
kind of like I mean we just stay here by
ourselves
um and she actually took she took longer
than me so um I ubered I ubered back to
them
I touched it I was like I'm so sorry
you're taking
so yeah just took the initiative I like
me since my our manager I was like sorry
I'm not waiting for the van I'm getting
home I need to go celebrate yeah
yeah ended up just had a shower whatever
and then caught up with our family
um unfortunately the celebration place
at with New Zealand Rugby you could only
bring four family members in uh I've got
a pretty big whanau there's probably 20
of them waiting in the casino for me
um so I had to choose your top four I
know I'm like oh that's a bit hard
um so yeah showed face obviously with
with them and then went back in yeah I
stayed at the casino with my family for
for a few hours but it was the next day
that was the best you probably heard
about it but we did we did get invited
on the ferry to waiheke Island to
celebrate it Ted's house then Wicked
host honestly they were so so so so so
cool and he put it on he put it on for
us and yeah we definitely downed a few
cold ones
um still buzzing out that we had
obviously just want to look up
yeah what's the party at Ted's like what
does he put on like
honestly he had every single breakfast
you could think of I was like damn it
must be nice
but I was
it was cool real cool Chill Vibes
um played games whatever we had dress up
we had to dress up
um and all that sort of stuff but
yeah he's a great host then I have to
share people only already talked about
um how cool it was to see smoothie and
Ted grow in a female environment
um obviously for the first time for them
it's very different so Lance
um but the emotion that they would
Express I remember Ted pretty much cried
it like a couple of our trainings just
of how proud he was to see the
progressions of the girls throughout the
year and each week throughout the
campaign um and he he didn't do too much
coaching
um he was just kind of the observing and
seeing everything but whenever he spoke
it was so cute and so inspiring um so
yeah it was pretty awesome to have him
in our environments and and share his
words of wisdom and the knowledge he's
gained over the years and all the many
experiences Herman and some of the
internet together um
uh that's very cool and how does that
sort of compare to uh Olympics when when
you win the Olympics you mentioned the
Rugby World Cup you enjoyed that one
more but what's winning an Olympic gold
medal like like must be pretty crazy as
well
yeah it's pretty cool I remember doing
projects at school on the Olympics and
getting us
um you know
um would you like to go there I'm like
how are you how are you I'd be amazing
like during the Olympic rings all the
time and doing all these different
studies on athletes
um I think I did Kathy Freeman I
definitely remember it I have no idea
why but I did choose her
um and doing like posters on these
athletes and and whatnot winning medals
at an Olympics um so it was kind of cool
when firstly just getting named I was
like whoa I'm actually going but then
you start thinking you start thinking oh
okay I need a um I need to get there
first like you could get injured you
could like so many things could happen
in such a short space of time
um so it's trying to find the balance of
not being stupid but also working hard
to make sure you you actually get there
um
so yeah obviously ran out for the first
time
um no crowd a little bit different but
knowing thousands we're watching back
home on TV it was cool and after the
first game I was like yeah okay this is
cool this is fun
um let's keep going to the end
um and after that final so it was it was
actually cool I remember the moment in
the final because I um I was on the
field and then I kind of got subbed I
think it was the last two three minutes
of the game and
I think we're up two tries so I was like
started to get a little bit more
confident and I was like oh yeah okay
that we're good here and then France
broke and then they scored a try so I
was like oh hang on it's getting close
and then we we had the ball our position
and then we once we did score our last
try I think it was maybe 30 seconds
before the game had finished we're like
celebrating on the sideline already
um knowing that we did it like it had
been a goal for us with one silver at
the last Olympics that I didn't actually
go to but I knew you know the the hurt
and the pain that the girls went through
on that Podium because they wanted a
gold medal
um
five years later after the other the
other Olympics are so yeah it was cool I
also remember I clearly remember my
feeling was
it was shock shock because when we're at
the Olympics and two we had just won an
Olympic gold medal and not everyone in
the world gets the opportunity to
actually attend the games like to just
be there is cool but then we won so
everyone's like in tears crying
and I'm just kind of like there like oh
we did it I I had no no emotion I was
stoked obviously ecstatic but yeah no
tears just like I don't know I have no
idea why but I stayed and shot for quite
a while until it finally sunk it
probably didn't sink in for for a little
bit didn't sleep that night
um when we had an early morning flight
the next day so yeah it was cool it was
special
um and I'm just grateful that I get that
opportunity so now obviously my family
called me or especially my brothers
um call me The Golden Child there's a
there's a little running joke in our
family that bows The Golden Child
because he's never really lived at home
and Mum and Dad do everything for her
because of that reason
um so we always thought oh he's The
Golden Child he's The Golden Child in
since winning the middle apparently I've
taken the title so I was like oh yeah I
feel good I'll take it claim it yeah not
a bad manager pick out but it's funny
you mentioned that feeling because I
always felt I didn't never want a gold
medal or a World Cup but every time I
won something significant I felt that
same feeling where I felt felt like I
should have been feeling more Buzz than
I was actually I was like man as I've
done it though is this is this it is
this the feeling why do I feel like
really really happy or like I yeah sort
of like what you're explaining there
like you're just sort of like oh I've
done it like yeah now what I think the
worst thing too was because all the girl
oh not all he actually pretty much all
the girls were just like in tears if you
see that we always give them a little
bit of stick because if you see the
close-up videos of them in slow-mo
they're just in like historical tears in
there you know those ugly cry faces you
do
um yeah and I don't know when you're
crying and I'm just like yay
this is amazing really wanting to love
it yeah
but yeah I was happy deep down inside
yeah no doubt Olympic gold Rugby World
cats I've done it all so what what are
the plans going forward obviously you've
got a World Series to win in the next
few weeks but yeah post that what what's
the plans for you going forward
um
yeah well I'm also share today because
I'm sure by the time that this podcast
is out everyone will start finding out
but oh if it's not this is our
announcement video
um obviously after the World Series we
usually go on a six-week Break
um compulsory
it's always um and then we've got
no World Series now until November
there's quite a big gap from like June
to November five six months and there's
no way I am doing that long a pre-season
I will just get bored out of my brains
uh so had the conversation with um our
coach and initially I just want to go
back to 15's I was like oh yep there's
some tournaments coming up this platform
I'll be Keen to go back in and he's like
yeah nah I don't think you should do
this and all that oh why not um got shot
down there
um so have to stick with Stevens and he
gave me another opportunity to go and
play in the the premier rugby sevens
over in America oh true
um so that competition is growing um you
actually get paid to play which is real
cool um depending on where you place
each tournament
um so yeah gonna hopefully hopefully
it's cleared I think it's cleared by now
from New Zealand Rugby to let me go over
there
um a few of us going just for the
experience
um I just
honestly I hate having long breaks I
hate pre-season I just love keep going
I'm like I'll just you know stay at a
I don't know at a level where I can
still might not be fit at my Peak at
certain times but I just don't want to
be unfair yeah I just hate it so much
that's just not me
um so it's like oh this is my way of not
having too much of a break and then
going into a two-month pre-season yeah
you're probably used to it but I'm not
because I just try and play everything
okay as well why not hey play I know I
know there's opportunity yeah it's like
why not um so yeah looking forward to
going over there for six weeks um I
think we're being based in San Diego
and then get to travel around the states
um depending on where the tournaments
are
um go play that then come back I think I
get the last four weeks of preseason I'm
like oh yeah that's not good I can deal
with it
and um yeah there's definitely a couple
of tournaments lined up I think maybe
one in Fiji maybe one in New Zealand
just with Aussie Fiji local teams before
the World Series kicks off again in
November and that's going to be massive
we've qualified for Olympics already
which is cool but now we have to try and
find suppose the right balance of
playing good rugby but not showcasing
too much right because you're going to
save some things for the the action
Olympics where you want to Peak really
peak man that's exciting though hey like
a cool opportunity again to travel see a
new experience make some money so do you
say you got prize money depending on
where you finish is that how you yeah
hope you're in a good team no I don't
even know what
it's like a draft but
yeah I'm I'm not 100 sure how it all
runs it's all real new and they're
trying to make it exciting and you know
in America how these NBA drafts and all
that sort of stuff they're trying to
find similar ways of making it fun like
that and you get to it'll be cool you'll
be first drafted sure
oh yeah
um so yeah I'll suppose just wait and
see
um what team I'm getting drafted into I
still think I get I think I get four
weeks off posts to loose so I'll still
get a decent break yeah um training but
not you know not having to be at a base
can just kind of do South direct stuff
um to lead into that tournament
um so yeah should be nice that's a
another mess of 12 months ahead yeah
another massive 12 months said you
called it and what about post foot it's
something that's come up quite a bit on
this podcast recently have you got much
plans for post footy or what's the sort
of dream for you um once rugby finishes
yeah
um thought about a few things so got a
few Qualls now obviously in sports and
did a bit of business stuff is it your
scrunchie business yeah yeah yeah yeah
so I started that after covert just a
lot a lot of fans wanting them and
actually kind of provoking me to to do
my own so that's kind of cool it is just
a side hustle though like I couldn't
live off it if I'm being honest but the
amount of people and young girls and
teams I can make happy I just that
inspires me and keeps me going so yes
takes up time but I love it is that
something you would look to potentially
grow yeah I've thought of it I've
definitely thought of owning my own
business one day I'd be pretty wicked I
know it wouldn't be easy
um but obviously dabbled in a bit of
media
um doing a little reporting stuff moldy
TV the last couple years in it's been a
real cool eye opener
um to be honest though I don't think I
would just want to stay in rugby if the
opportunity came in it was obviously
good enough for my future whatever I
wanted to do oh I'd jump at it but I
think I I just love sport in general
um so whether
it's doing stuff in New Zealand
traveling the world again as long as it
revolves around sport I'll be pretty
happy that's what gets me up every day
that I'm obviously passionate about it
in in so many different ways um so that
could obviously be an opportunity too
but I'm not finished playing it so I'm
just saying you got plenty of views I'm
just gonna keep playing in yeah little
rumors about potentially going off to
play league obviously a lot of
opportunity now
um with that so I'm not going to say no
I'm not going to close the door to any
other codes but I will the the goal is
to get to the next Olympics um and then
we'll reassess after that sure I didn't
know is is it Lee quite big for the
woman over there and yeah yeah so
they've got like Dr they like have
Marquee players and everything the the
money has grown so much I honest I think
like it's weird Stevens was maybe six
years ago
um there's a minimum contract of 30k
that's like for the whole team obviously
you have different tiers and levels but
like yeah you've got girls on 100K over
there that's oh true definitely lovable
for you know that kind of kind of season
so yeah yeah might might give it a devil
who knows by the rules but all in them
well there we go another yeah yeah
see Stacy walk us off to the NRL woman
what is it called for the women's the W
nrlw on the woman's towards the end um
well we've obviously got Gail Broughton
playing over there she's code yeah there
are a few Aussie girls Aussie sevens
girls who have already made the switch
um over there uh so to be fair I reckon
there'll be more people more people
doing it I mean I know there are more
people doing it but I'm not going to
share who that is yet you'll find out in
the meantime I look forward to finding
out that wherever the Manny goes hey
that's where the players and the people
end up going as it's like yeah at the
moment look at man everyone's trying to
get to Japan at such a flooded market
for these high level
Internationals at the moment uh the
money's good why wouldn't you take it
really it's it's yeah 100 and I always
talked about like when I make decisions
for different opportunities and whatnot
it's for me I like obviously have these
goals they run his goals and dreams that
they want to work towards but I'm so
grateful to have achieved literally not
everything I mean most things
um in rugby I still haven't won a
provincial title for sevens or 15s and
that'll always haunt me I've never won
always come round
another one and a gold medal in the
World Cup fight you know where it all
starts it provincial level that's always
where pretty much your career starts
with everything after Club um so yeah I
just I think it's time potentially time
depending on how the next couple years
go on on a new challenge but we'll see
we'll see I might not want to leave New
Zealand Rugby is actually pretty good
get some pretty cool incentives here
yeah well exciting times ahead no matter
what you choose no doubt it's going to
be successful but as always we have gone
to our Instagram for some questions and
well you have some seriously I'm gonna
say obsessive fans who maybe asked 2015
questions each because they obviously
big fans of yours which just goes to
show how much you are loved
um boy a lot of young girls around the
world but one of the main ones was
around the change of last name I think
this one came with probably about 15
times so you've obviously changed your
last name back uh what's Stacey flu
letter now Stacy Walker what's the
insight there yes
yes
um
Lee
um had made the split decision with my
now ex-husband
um So currently not together anymore
um and you know it's honestly all
amicable very amicable
um things just weren't meant to be and
the decision had to be made for The Best
of Both Worlds
um I suppose and yeah I suppose new
journey ahead
um zero regrets on everything oh it was
great it was a great time well it lasted
in oh I loved carrying his family name
they are the the coolest people in the
world like had some of my best moments
in life with them and they're the best
supporters too they're throughout all
the World Cups and com games supporting
100 and it was an honor to obviously
we're his name but
like I said unfortunately things didn't
go to plan as we had hoped or expected
in life and yeah I'm yeah we are no
longer together but it's all good you
know got the right support behind both
of us
um and yeah obviously we're showing all
the best with with his future and he's
done the same and yeah we kind of just
move on and go from there oh mate it's
good to hear so how hard is that
changing that last name obviously it's
big decision for all the women athletes
when they do find love that they have to
change their last name they create a
brand around their first last name and
then they change it and then yeah
that's that's funny that's funny because
we do talk about it and I honestly
reckon it's like situation dependent so
some girls they're probably like the
last person in their family to carry
their family name so they're just like
no there's no way I'm changing my name I
was complete opposite so my dad has 17
16 siblings or 16 16. so he's one of 16.
wow autumn autumn and cuddle like
obviously same family
um and he's my dad as the third to
youngest and then there will at least
got four kids each so you do the math
I've literally got like way over 50
first cousins and to be honest a lot of
them are male so there's 10 boys Seven
Girls six girls in alfano
um there's a lot of workers in the world
so when I got the opportunity to change
my last name I was like oh wow it's
definitely that is definitely gonna
happen like that's all good here we are
not gonna lose our name anytime yeah
um so big whanau and I just thought of
like cool for him because he actually
Ricky played rugby growing up and he was
awesome he never quite made up because
of injuries and whatnot
um and his dream was to to become more
black as every young boy you know dreams
of doing yeah um but didn't make it so
he obviously made black Fern and then
for me to obviously carry their name
um on the back of a black Jersey it was
special and I remember the first time I
did it it was real cool
um I was actually here at home at the
Hamilton sevens in 2020. before
yeah
um so yeah it was it was cool but like I
said unfortunate things happen and back
to Waka I'm still trying to get used to
it I'm going to be honest I'm like Oh
Stacy worker my whole life and the last
three years I haven't been now I've got
to try and you know change back and sign
things and remember oh actually yeah new
signature again forget about that yeah
yeah
I can't believe your the old man was one
of 16. that's crazy crazy three was a
lot of kids
um I still meet family members to this
day like this is so true that you've
never met yeah well that's cool and
that's what I loved about outbringing
and there's so many people around all
the time and you know you just come over
and you just make it work you just make
things work with lots of people in the
house yeah very good like that one okay
next one did you ever not smile while
scoring a try and how did The Smiling
start
small
well usually when I'm in the red like
I'm absolutely naked on the field
there's there's no way or no time to
smile
pull it down
um so yes to answer that question
there's definitely moments probably not
lots but there are moments in I actually
compiled a whole lot of photos there's
obviously a lot of smiling ones but the
other times there's usually finding
someone you know when you just got to
try and be like real aggressive and
you're like a bit aggressive kind of
thing those are when it kind of screws
up it's also another time when I'm not
smiling and let's jumping for the ball
in the air all I see is my face like
screwed up and my eyes closed when they
should be open but all good
you're doing well if you're smiling
going up for that you didn't know yeah
no that's definitely it's commitment to
the smile and yeah not sure where it
started or how it started but
if I remember the series where I got so
unfortunately the year Porsche got
injured she did an accolades
um I started getting a bit more game
time because obviously being
Porsches you just stay behind it because
she's amazing yeah
um I got my opportunity to play more on
the World Series and I was just having a
ball I was just having fun and I think
that's where Ricky funnel commentator
from here
um nicknamed me The Smiling assassin
because I was just loving it like just
enjoyed my time on the field and I was
like oh my God this is so cool like all
the game time I was getting
um and yeah it's just kind of float on
from then I think it was four years ago
now now you definitely look like it you
definitely look like you're loving your
time out on the field which is just very
cool to say okay next one favorite
sidestepper
yeah
he'll want me he'll want me to say him
no he's not getting that credit today
favorite side stepper
oh that's real hard because I've played
alongside like some pretty awesome
people and I'm gonna be biased and
choose someone I've played with not
against
um and
if I have to go like present or like
kind of most recent
um player within the last few years oh
now I feel like I'm being biased because
if I'm gonna be like why didn't you save
me
but I'm gonna say her because she's not
playing anymore she just retired last
year and she was a legend of the game
and she doesn't get the credit she
deserves as
Renee Wycliffe or Renee Woodman Wycliffe
now
um like such an underdog she's been
playing for years
more and more known as Portia's Porsha's
wife at the moment but I think it's like
Renee is um you know other way other way
around
[Laughter]
um she if you watch highlights of her
stepping honest to God it is unreal and
she was one of those who I used to watch
footage of growing up you know you start
learning about past players yeah and
back in the day playing touch playing
rugby
um it's hard it's so hard to defend
um and whatnot so yeah I'm gonna give
the credit too well now all my black
friend Stephen sisters
today that's who I thought of first oh
fair enough you go with your gut because
it's generally true okay next one Stace
tell them about your chip and Chase and
the Bay of Plenty under 18 final now I
always love stories like that sounds
like a good try
I'm here but I don't know you know you
see an opportunity and your body just
kind of does things reacts without
thinking and that's what I did so yeah
pretty stoked about the trip and Chase
there I've never done it again you know
what why not that's the actual my goal
it's important sevens it's literally one
of my goals at the moment I would love
to bring it back out again on the world
stage that's one of my goals and also to
click my own conversion one day but not
yet we'll see we'll see about that
um great memories in that bay of Plenty
on the 18s team
um loved it still fresh airs to rugby
like I said I played fullback didn't
even know how to cook didn't know yeah
many rules still probably learning the
game
um but yeah it was cool time it was cool
time with with the girls back then just
just playing for fun and obviously
representing our profits so did your
chip and Chase the fullback well yeah
were you one-on-one
yeah no it wasn't it wasn't I don't even
think there was a fallback it
yeah good
okay two more what's the most impactful
things rugby has taught you
oh yeah we're going deeper here that's
great that's
that's and uh put that down to one thing
um the most impactful thing about rugby
um I think for me
the biggest thing that I've learned or
uh the the quote I love quotes I
absolutely love quotes actually I've got
two favorite quotes that I really have
to say sweet say them both but those are
my um I suppose the impacts it has had
on my life and my careers the first one
is nothing with having ever comes easy
so you quickly learn and sport or when
rugby or professional
um life or sporting athlete life that
you have to work hard like I was I had I
knew I had Talent um and like I said I
got turned away because Talent was just
only going to get me so far
um but you know you have to dive in
those dark deep places that's definitely
something I always think about I'm like
you can never just be given things you
have to work for it you have to earn it
um and and it makes it much more sweeter
so obviously being injured many times
and that's the quote that kind of helped
me get through it's like yeah all good
um it's not easy but it'll always be
worth it that that's one thing and the
second one probably very similar is it
everything always happens for a reason
very cliche
um but mentally I honestly think that
helped me that has helped me the last
eight years
um get throughout this career this
amazing career that has taken me around
the world is trying to not get upset on
all the small things that happen it's
like it's all good like yep you're
injured or yep you dropped the ball or
yep you're gonna get selected for this
it's okay there's always something else
um there's a reason for it even if you
never figure out the reason it's all
good but mentally no it keeps you in the
game so yeah those little impacts I
suppose on on those learnings being
being professional and and trying to
juggle life and you know it's tough it's
tough one you know how it is trying to
drag all your family or friends your
hobbies your career everything it's
tough but yeah yeah those are little
things that that have impacted me and
made me a better not just a better
player because I always think of the
overall whole whatever the overall
well-being of being a bit focus them
I like that and a couple of nice quotes
and that's probably going to go into
this next question last question that I
ask everyone is best piece of advice you
have for a water LED listener and you've
given a couple of quotes maybe early
yeah yeah go again
you've got more she's got more I've got
more I've got more
um I think for me now especially towards
I want to say my in because I still got
a little bit of me I think I'm only 27.
um I think the biggest I suppose piece
of advice
for you what all ad listeners
um is to
understand the importance of balance of
your whole life obviously you can get
caught up in being working hard
um whether at a sport whether you're a
teacher whether you're a chef whether
you're absolutely anything in the world
um that you don't forget about anything
else I feel like if you want to give
your best in life then you know you want
to achieve big things you can't just
stick to one thing you've got to try and
do your best to continue looking after
your family be there for your friends
who have always been there for you day
one and try and get it for me like I
think our balance is not 50 50 equal to
anything
um something's always going to take
priority over something else at a
certain stage in your life or a certain
part of the year
um but for me it's it's getting that
balance right because too often we work
so hard and we're so ambitious and
passionate about our hobby or sorry our
dream job yeah that we forget the little
moments and and that's something I've
definitely noticed or realized the last
few years is give yourself time
um yeah that that's definitely important
you you can't just keep giving giving
you have to fill your cup up in in other
ways so um yeah you can like I said have
a better oh holder overall not just
focusing on one thing that's been a The
Messer part of my journey my growth is
that you know I just did kapaka on the
weekend because I love my culture yeah
it was like a small amount of time that
I gave to it but it really filled my cup
up in my soul and when I came back to
training on Monday I was like reading I
was like whoa this is so cool like I've
done something for my whanau for my
culture for my community now it's time
to step back on the training field get
ready to go and win the solo sevens and
you know you kind of have those little
goals and you put more effort and time
into those things um when it comes so
yeah rambled on a bit there but as you
get the chance I get it and what a piece
of advice geez that was one of the best
ever love that one from you and what a
way to finish what is one of the
greatest podcasts um really appreciate
you giving up your time and coming on
um you're like I said at the start
you're an inspiration for so many not
just in New Zealand but like I said
around the world with what you've done
in the women's game and just like so
many fans who just obviously obsessed
with you and love you and uh you're
inspiring them to get into the game that
we all love so awesome having you on
podcast and hearing a story from the
start and what a story it's been and
hopefully for many more years good luck
over in America yeah and then over in
the NRL W
hopefully exciting times ahead for you
so look forward to following you yeah I
think thanks bro and thanks everyone for
listening
um I'm not done yet I've still got more
things to achieve but um yeah we're
definitely
um see you guys out there